[Music]
kate hudson flashes her shaved head in a
sports bra and short shorts
we only live once
[Music]
the 38 year olds recently ditched her
long locks for her role in sister a
movie written and directed by the
australian singer sia it's amazing and
on wednesday the hollywood a-lister was
spotted rocking her bold new cut on the
set of the film in l.a
i'm just always happy to be here while
not much is known about the new project
we do know the mom of two looked fit and
fierce in a baby blue sports bra and
matching short shorts that showed off
her fit physique
kate debuted her new do in july
you heard it here first
posting this pic of her on set to
instagram with the caption freedom
a few days later kate shared this shot
of her and her boyfriend musician danny
fujikawa dirt bike riding with her 13
year old son ryder
i love them
in august she posted this pic with her
sister co-star former dance mom star
maddie ziegler checking out the eclipse
on set in new york
we had just had a great time together
and we have to say she is slaying the
buzz cut look
oh my god
e.t caught up with maddie at the teen
choice awards in august
and she couldn't help but gush over kate
she's becoming like a family member to
me so i love her so much
[Music]